I'm saying it's like you're we had  literally just talked about this off  camera when we when you guys picking up  from the airport we were talking about  oh what what's the value system or the  point system for a woman who cooks  versus a woman who can suck good dick  and [ __ ] well but you like cooking  something because what I'm saying is  it's that Pearl it you can crave if I'm  wrong but um quoting her was that and  when she interviewed people on the  street that there was more points given  to something for like a sexual return as  opposed to oh wash this is my hand  there's a dishwasher why cook we can eat  out there's a chef people don't get they  don't give a [ __ ] about that that's what  they think but we literally just talked  about this yesterday yeah it was